hello my name is nicholas chia and i'm
pleased to be presenting to you today on
machine learning approaches for modeling
complex community dynamics
now this touches upon one of my favorite
topics which is modeling complex
community dynamics which is thinking
about how especially in the microbiome
world and milieu of different species
get together to perform important tasks
that affect our health
or or promote disease
now this is classically been a task that
is essentially too hard for the human
mind to encompass all of that complexity
at once
but over the last decade or so there's
been a growth in machine learning
approaches that really augment our
ability to embrace that complexity and
understand what's going on in the
complex ecosystem
that is the human body
so let's start with a non-human body
first
here's the teslabot you may have heard
of it this is elon musk's dream that
we're all going to own a tesla bot and
it's going to help us go uh do some
perform some mundane tasks like shopping
for groceries um it's also going to uh
help us perform monday and sort of
mental tasks and physical tasks like
looking at a bunch of apples and saying
well this one's the bad one so i'm going
to throw it out and i'm only going to
keep the good ones
and that's pretty much been the story of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
up until now we've really talked about
mostly scaling up mundane tasks
or
some some standard classification and
sorting algorithms where we're trying to
sort class a from class b
and that's true in the microbiome world
as well you could think of a random
forest as a mundane task of setting up
many many many decision trees and then
using those
to classify disease from health like in
this example where we're looking at the
role of
bmi and obesity and colorectal cancer
uh other examples of classification come
from the deep neural network world uh
deep learning which has touched many
many fields
and it's been used in examples like this
one
for drug response
where
dr sung's lab has published a paper
looking at
how predictive the microbiome is
for ra drugs and it turns out the
microbiome is the most predictive
feature
out of the mixture of features clinical
and microbiome and metabolomic
and these are some of the reasons why
machine learning approaches have become
so important
in the microbiome world
now that being said
if you just look at the headlines you
know their their review articles just
within the last year or so and i just
pulled these out these are not
represents of everything but if you look
at all of the review articles talking
about machine learning and the
microbiome you will see almost all of
them fall into this category
of basic classification and sorting
well you know as someone with a
quantitative background
i have to say that these tasks are not
really satisfying i mean these are all
just about dividing uh data up into
different spaces using deep neural
networks finding uh uh you know the
the the line that separates data points
and and that's a very important task for
biomarkers but it's not as far as we
could go with machine learning it's not
to me using the best use
making the best use of advanced machine
learning that we have today
so
this is really not a very satisfying
feeling because you know my feeling is
is that we really want to gain insight
out of these systems we unders we want
to understand what the causal drivers
are we want to understand what the
underlying processes are that give rise
to disease and health
and biomarkers are
good for prediction in certain things
but they're not
they're not helping us understand the
science which as an academic is really
what gives you that satisfying feeling
of being able to move the world forward
so the question i'm going to pose today
is can we use machine learning to
improve microbiome modeling
and so examples of modeling community
dynamics come in many forms
one example is from the lock of altera
case over here which is a very simple uh
case many of you have seen before it
basically um
involves species species interactions
and so if two species help each other
grow they have a positive interaction
this beta term is is becomes uh i guess
uh
a
positive well i guess in this case it
would be a a negative term to make this
positive growth wise um
or or vice versa if they hurt each other
they really have a negative term and so
on
uh conway's game of life which is really
talking about spatial interactions
conway's game of life is a game where
depending on how many neighbors you have
you have different
birth and death processes if you're all
alone you die if you're sort of next to
a few people you know you you give birth
and if you're you know have too many
people you overpopulate and and people
die
and this shows you that even with simple
spatial interactions you can get sort of
these complex patterns
and then lastly metabolic modeling
which is an area that
that i've personally dabbled in and
enjoy and uh it really has to do with
how can we turn the biochemical
constraints that we know the biological
knowledge
and put that all together into a giant
understanding of reaction fluxes and use
constraint based flux balance approaches
to make uh pointed predictions and this
has been used for community dynamics as
well on a limited basis
and so this is a picture of john conway
and the reason i put this picture here
is to say that these are all limited by
the human mind these approaches all of
them
we really are having trouble scaling
these up
because we are very very finite beings
and
you know we don't communicate oddly
enough as well as computers do with each
other and so we don't scale up uh in the
same way computers can
so how can we scale up these complex
models so first let's go over what a
complex model is fundamental definition
of a complex model is that it has lots
and lots of members and it's strongly
interacting
so
i say that so that we all agree that in
order to understand the complex model we
are going to need to scale up
and personally i think they're very fun
um because they're not very
straightforward they involve
a little bit of convolutedness and
answering them and complexity uh but for
people who just want the answer to the
biology as why this happens they're a
little bit painful right i mean in some
sense the reason why we are going after
biomarkers for medicine is because you
know you don't want your doctor to
really wonder about your diagnosis so
much you really want them to just give
you a diagnosis and and you know use one
marker and say that's it i know the
answer but that's not really realistic
because in a complex system like most
biological systems the interactions
and not the members determine the
behavior of the system
in other words the interactions become
stronger than the nature of the members
themselves and so when you're looking at
individual biomarker you're really
looking at
one entity in the system right one type
of agent one species
but you're not looking at the
interactions and i will put out that the
interactions are more important
and these interactions often give rise
to collective effects that create
seemingly ordered behavior and that's
exactly the kind of thing that we want
to understand
right what makes for
certain types of gut bacteria
configurations
what creates a healthy system what does
dysbiotic mean you know all these sorts
of questions that we want to know
and one example of this collective
behavior is the formation of biofilms
microbes do this all the time they start
growing as individual cells they form
larger bodies eventually they form these
complex structures
and even fruiting bodies that go off and
then seed other things and so so without
these collective effects we wouldn't be
able to understand even a biofilm of a
single species forget about the
collective dynamics of many many species
and this is something that i modeled
once in the past so this example wasn't
pulled out of nowhere and i have shown
that we can model the formation
of a biofilm
using a set of master equations similar
to the lack of altera equations
so going back to lack of altera how are
we going to scale this up
well
one way that we looked at
was taking log of altera
putting out the generalized lock of
altera equation where this is the rate
of change of a species x i
uh this is the rate of growth this is
the carrying capacity k over here and
here these alpha ijs specify the species
species interactions
and what we managed to show using data
from jeff gore's lab
that was published previously is that
even for a three-way system three
interactions
the lock of altera model had a lot of
trouble
accurately depicting these relationships
so
based on the pairwise react interaction
so that's to say that if an experiment
was done with just two species
and each pair was simulated
uh together
then putting all three of them together
uh with the same interaction term did a
really really poor job and this these
plots down here are showing the
deviation
uh from what we would expect based on
the pairwise interactions
interaction terms
so this kind of showed us that uh
this didn't work very well overall and
we tested this for larger systems and
and we tested this by just looking at
well what happens if we just simulate
each species individually
just looking at the carrying capacity
what happens if we fit based on the
pairwise growth data where
gore's lab did this wonderful work where
they actually grew up each pair and each
organism individually and then they
compared growth rates um in a community
and outside of the community
and what we find is that
these data points don't fit the data
very well when we want to put together a
whole system
and if we were to fit the whole system
naively we could do a much much better
job of it although we still have some
problems so the issue with this is of
course this is this this fundamental
model is not quite working uh and it's
not quite scaling up very well so um
and we can see that because in these
three different configurations we get
very very different parameter values
overall this is showing the percentage
of parameter values that stays the same
across these three circumstances
so so pairwise growth parameters don't
inform a community like a volterra model
very well making this particular model
not particularly good uh in its
formulation for scaling up
yet we all love the lock of altera model
because mentally we can understand what
a species species interaction is
but why is it failing right it's
probably failing because we're missing
um
some kind of interaction so so the lack
of altered description is not sufficient
so what do we do so what we did in our
work was we looked at changing the form
of the equations to account for more
biology in our case because of uh prior
experience with metabolic modeling we
said why don't we try a metabolite
mediated model which is to say that
these microbes are not having direct
species species interactions but they're
interacting through the medium of some
kind of metabolite
and that allows for more complex forms
and and as you can see we can now model
the same thing and we can add
metabolites and
and this becomes more complex and it
also allows us to have more fitting
parameters uh and so it's of course
probably no surprise that that worked
really well
but it also created a really large space
of possibilities
that again relies on human cleverness to
sort of uh curate and understand how to
search appropriately right
otherwise the computer could fit based
on any metabolite it really wanted to
but those might not be the real driver
metabolites
so
so can we
use machine learning
to identify the new functional forms uh
to describe complex systems based on
limited time longitudinal data that's
the question i'm going to pose right now
and and bring forward and show you an
example of
so
the answer is yes uh and i'm going to
show you some work based on a a piece of
the package that's actually remarkably
easy to download and run
that basically
tries to guess what the functional forms
are
and tries to force
those functional forms to be as sparse
as possible that is to have as few terms
as possible
which make it easier to understand from
the human under trying to interpret it
on the other end
so we start with a system of equations
so let me go really slowly here
this is again
on the left hand side of the equation
the rate
of change in x and x can be a species
for instance and there might be many x's
x
1 x 2 x 3.
there is then on the right hand side a
function describing the rate of change
that depends
on the value of
x at a time t
so an example of that
that you all might be familiar with by
now is the sir model that has been
talked about in covet 19 quite a bit
where you have a susceptible population
whose rate in change over time
is given
in proportion to the number of infected
people and the number of susceptible
people they come in contact with and
that's very intuitive because the number
of infected people can go on and infect
more people so the more infections you
have the more rampant it is in the
community
but if there are no susceptible people
it's not going to spread anywhere so
you're not going to grow or lose in this
case because the minus sign any of your
susceptible people
right
so you need a mixture of both
likewise
you have your your infected people and
and they continue to grow according to
the same term because susceptible people
become infected people and uh and then
you know there's some exit rate for this
this system as well
so this is this is an example that you
all might be familiar with just just so
that we understand how this system of
equations works
so uh when we're setting up this problem
what we can do uh using pi cindy is uh
specify a number of functional forms
polynomial forms uh of the different
species x1 x2 so on
and they can be uh
they can be directly proportional they
can be proportional to uh the square uh
the cube and so on and we're going to
set we're going to give it a certain
number of terms to search and then it
also uh can can do these in combination
as well where it's uh you can have terms
where um species one is interacting with
species two species one is interacting
with species one and two and three and
so on in all different combinations with
different powers
up to a certain amount
and uh and
pi cindy says if we can if we can uh
if we if we can make the number of
non-zero terms sparse then we can solve
for the functional form quite well and
very quickly
and as an example of that
we went back to the lock of altera
because everybody likes and for two
species lack of altera we can set up our
own equations set the coefficients and
and look at the the true vector field
and plot it and then we can generate
these five trajectories
well what we can do then is give those
trajectories over to pi cindy and we can
have it impute the vector field over the
whole space and as you can see it does
really really well
just with five trajectories it does a
perfect job essentially of recapturing
a low order equation that describes the
lockable terra vector field
so
that's really good and the question is
could we do it for something more
complex well
if we want to consider a microbiome we
consider all the different absolute
species and species abundances
and we can take this example
uh from
from stephanie's song and and my
collaborator wellesley mark to tell
where they gathered
daily vaginal samples across the course
of 11 weeks or so
and we can take each of these as a
trajectory
and
as a discrete trajectory and then we can
use the same approach to try to
understand the equations of motion
essentially that describe the vector
field
of the microbiome of the vaginal
microbiome
there's the rate of change you'll notice
in the abundance of species x
and i'll just note that this is
approximately the difference between two
subsequent time points
and when we do that and we plot this out
we get something very interesting right
we get a very compelling result which is
that we can generate that vector field
then we can take a random point in the
vector field and we can simulate forward
and we find that we get behavior that's
very similar to what we see in real life
this is the relative abundance of l
inners and blue this is in christmas and
orange and you see here from this
example you have this switching where
this is purple uh this is for spotis is
purple and blue is uh lactobacillus
inners and you can see that they switch
in dominance
very rapidly
and we have that same behavior captured
in our model as well
in addition to that the other thing that
very hap often happens in fact in the
same person just in year 2 of this study
we
we have elk respondus dominance and that
dominance often does not you know it it
fluctuates downward but it really
doesn't go anywhere uh
across time
and and here you know
we have similar behavior although i'll
note there's a numerical instability um
[Music]
and that this is preliminary data that
we're still working through but it's
it's a compelling quantitative result
that we've produced here
so one last thought here
is that
you can think of this
rate of change also as the replication
rate of species x
and for that if you have metagenomics
time longitudinal sampling you actually
can use one of these metagenomic growth
rate estimators there are a few of them
around uh two examples are sort of shown
here um and if you have that you could
perhaps replace this side and actually
improve your estimate even further
i of course am not going to show an
example of that because i don't have
that data but if anybody does feel free
to email me
if if you would like to collaborate and
give that a try
all right
so that's one way in which we can use
machine learning to to improve these
sorts of
uh understanding approaches right
approaches to understanding biology
another one i'd like to
talk about is an evolution and the
particular example we looked at in this
case was cancer evolution but this could
be applied to any population including
microbial populations
and for those you unfamiliar with cancer
one of the paradigms of cancer is that
it starts with a mutation
that mutation grows because it creates a
polarificative advantage
um
more mutations accumulate and so on and
and that's the process of cancer
evolution
until you get to you know a tumor that
that causes health problems
now we can simulate that by considering
genes
in a genome
those genes can have a value of 0 or 1
in our simulation
which is to say 0 is normal and 1 is
mutated
and just for simplicity we can start
with a genome with only
four gene loci
and there are only two driver locis at
the very end at the beginning and end of
that genome
and so that means the cancer genomes are
given by these four genomes over here
that have a one in the first position
and the one in the last position
and the non-cancer genomes are all the
ones that have a zero and one of those
positions are
both and so we can simulate this forward
now
that is we can simulate the evolution of
cancer we can mark down
the progression of that cancer and then
we can use those
um to try to understand
what's happening now how are we going to
use those
well we can use a technique called
inverse reinforcement learning and i
don't want to dive too deep into this
but inverse reinforcement learning
basically takes a set of expert
demonstrations
which is to say
demonstrations of cancer evolution and
it
infers a reward function
that describes
the incentives and preferences that that
agent is going to behave with
that is to say it's understanding how
cancer behaves it's forming the reward
map of cancer in this case and from our
example i already told you that the
first and last because we put this in we
knew what the answer was i told you that
the first and last position
were the positions that were driver
mutations and what you can see in this
simulation
is that indeed that's true
the first position in the last position
if you have if they're both zero are
approximately equally rewarded in this
reward map
in terms of these actions which are
mutating the first or the last position
if the first position is already mutated
the last position is what really wants
to be picked up
if it's the opposite the last position
is mutated then the first position is
the one that's the most rewarding and so
you can see that this reward function
describes the behaviors
that would drive cancer and so this
becomes a really interesting paradigm
for understanding cancer evolution
and the question we ask
is can we learn what incentivizes tumor
growth
can we take
the behavior of cancer that is the
expert demonstrations that come from
cancer
which we're going to estimate using
tumor phylogeny
and recover meaningful reward functions
that describe
tumor growth
so for this we created an algorithm
which we called the pop-up restaurant
for uh inverse reinforcement learning or
pure irl
the reason we call it the pop-up
restaurant process is because
it involves essentially a lot of chinese
restaurant processes for partitioning
expert demonstrations into different
reward functions
and because the name matches quite well
a pop-up restaurant is a short-term
restaurant that allows chefs to try out
new concepts new audiences and
experiment with new ingredients and
that's pretty much what we're doing
we're trying new reward functions
reshuffling the expert demonstrations
into different restaurants and and
trying uh different types of data in all
of these until we find sort of the best
result
and again not going to go into the
details of this
but you know truth in advertising this
is the pure irl implementation and
anyone who wants to read this is welcome
to go through our paper which uh i'll
i'll show at the end of the talk
so the result of this
is that
we showed that the two most
rewarded paths the two most likely paths
that occur after learning the reward
functions
are these two shown here this is sort of
the reward this is the reward function
up here although it's really hard to
read because you can see this space is
really really large
what i can say about this space is that
they're about 10 to the 200 possible
places you can go here
or different orders in which you can do
things
and the top two give us these uh
orderings abc k ras maybe smab 4 tp53
leading to cancer and what's really
interesting is this exactly matches the
second path exactly matches
the 1990 seminal paper by fearson and
vogelstein which described the
progression of colorectal cancer that is
still considered canonical today
so in other words we managed to
rediscover this path uh and we only used
data from 27 patients with no time
longitudinal data just inferring
based on tumor phylogeny which gives us
only a very approximate sense of time
but this really shows us the power of
this method and it has the potential to
add it doesn't just rediscover what
humans already know it has the potential
to discover new things
and so some of these new things we
looked at some of the more likely
transitions from normal that were
considered drivers in this model
and
we found these papers for all three of
these we instantly found papers that
indicated either experimental evidence
or epidemiological evidence from meta
studies
that showed these are
early drivers
in colorectal cancer
so this is really a new paradigm for us
pushing forward
to use the computer to augment
biological understanding
so in conclusion i want us all to
understand that biological systems are
really complex and have complex behavior
machine learning is a way in which we
can embrace that
and especially exciting
are the growth avenues uh that involve
understanding the infinite dynamics such
as those infinite dynamics
that include um you know evolution
or microbiome behavior ecological
behavior and those are the areas that
are really exciting and upcoming in the
future for the microbiome fields here
are a bunch of papers for future reading
and i want to give thanks to everyone in
the lab for this and my collaborators my
funding sources i'll uh highlight a few
people in particular here john
collentari
who now runs his own lab and group
within mayo clinic
was the post-doc who who did the work on
inverse reinforcement learning jiren
berner did the work on the ecological
models and the metabolite mediated
models and is now moving on to uh
postdoc in los alamos national lab
stephanie song who i mentioned earlier
provided the vaginal microbiome data
for us to work with
and
yash law actually did the work uh with
the vector fields
that i showed in the middle of this talk
so thank you very much
and with that
i hope you all had a good time